[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
amazing amazing episode of the careful
boys all right it's very affectionate
episode don't touch my can like that bro
it's yours let them go what we talk
about like he got here first I did get
her first it's that thing fight for me
come on you you stay in your seat you're
in frame okay can't work hard to keep
you in frame you [__] stay there I
can't leave what we talk about today Joe
suggested we talk about this oh I like
this Joe go ahead and suggest
we're going to talk about dating oh yeah
what about dating
specifically what goes on in the DMS and
I am so curious who is hitting on who I
think Anthony's hitting on me yeah he is
I think you can stop making this about
you right now specifically NPR recently
came out with this article showing the
frequency of who be hitting up who in
the DMS and who respond resp to who in
the DMS but they categorize through
ethnicity pull out the data pull the
data bu if really just Joe or Anthony P
the who likes let's talk about how the
odds favor white men and Asian women on
dating apps okay but the category is we
got white we got the black we got the
Asian and we got the Latino okay so wait
before we give the data let's guess okay
what's your yes as far as who gets the
most attention on the male Spectrum yeah
I would probably
say you said white black Asian and
Hispanic yep I would probably say white
first okay rank them it's not in uh is
it in ranking for this is men this is
men ranking so so so women talking to
men correct okay so probably white white
dudes get the most is that what you're
saying black black dudes get the second
spanic Asian is that pretty good mhm
well it seems like women on this
list the way that they have this graph
the way you the way that it's done it's
not like ranking okay but it's like the
way that it's like what the [__] is that
give me the math man I was right well it
just it shows the highest likelihood so
it's like if you're Asian if you're an
Asian guy you're likely hitting on okay
so if you're a black dude if you're a
black dude you're likely hitting on this
type of so are white guys primar
responses it's response so like let's
say someone shoots the shot or they
respond to you at like the frequency of
responses so if a white guy hits up x
amount of people in the DMS their
Primary Response is from Asian women
that's what it is
they're show them the graph so they
know I thought it was just very simple
like who's who's trying to get with who
make it simpler for us I got preference
yeah let's just make it up let's make
assumptions who would be hit up the most
out of okay so out of the 2.4 million
heterosexual interactions researchers
review the finding
right women get three times the
interactions men do I think we all could
have said yeah that's
[__] I like all men seem to be more
interested in people outside of their
race wow
interesting that's cool um black men and
women get the lowest response rates to
their
messages all women except black women
are are most drawn to white men and men
of all
Races with one notable exception prefer
Asian women who is the notable exception
Asian men Asian men Asian men yeah
probably cuz Asian cuz it's like they're
going outside going outside yeah which
is interesting I didn't know that's
pretty most people are shooting their
shots outside of their race that's cool
hey guys we defeated racism good job
good job everybody can't believe I just
everybody's just trying to she watches
her
hands in this chart it's except for
black women black women respond to black
men but black men don't respond to black
women black men respond to Asian women
in terms of the highest black men are
not yeah they're not like hitting up
black women as much so the Okay Cupid
data I have no idea OK Cupid data said
black women respond the most to their
DMS white men get more replies from
almost every group white women prefer
white men Asian and Latina women prefer
them even more
exclusively I don't know what that means
Asian and Latino women like white men
more the most they respond to them more
exclusively got it got got got it so
then the graph looks like this flip it
around and show them
it's a big it's like a
web all right there it is there it
is
Boom screenshot that has been flipped
and shown black women to black men Asian
oh see I knew it as white to
white all white B everybody want to B an
Asian girl and every guy yeah wants to B
A Asian girl all the girls want to talk
to a white guy except for black women
they want to talk to black men that's
interesting are you guys surprised by
any of any of these no I mean that's
kind of what's already been going around
it's funny because it's kind of
confirming stereotypes it is yeah it is
and it's it's funny too because nobody
can see your mess these are all
Anonymous results out of 2.4 million I
think it's a good sample size if more
authentic preference it's more authentic
you're not being judged by now let's
make our clear assumptions on ha okay
this is the oh but you know what's also
interesting aside from this is that
these are digital like interactions I
wonder if the results are the same out
in the world like who do you feel more
comfortable
approaching you know cuz you could just
DM anybody but then you can't really
walk up to just about anybody and like
feel the same comfortability off
the the theory of these are more
authentic
preferences then wouldn't you gauge that
these people would want to meet up with
them yeah but but I don't know if it's
like the same in terms of if you were
like in a bar do you have the uh does an
Asian guy have the you know at least the
courage to walk up to someone outside is
race just cold talk the same way that
you could just digitally go hey what's
up you know and there's no skin off your
back it's always going to be a little
bit more comfortable regardless but
maybe that's the truest like what their
really truly desired it's Anonymous and
it's just easy accessibility wise it's a
lot easier well it's definitely not
Anonymous but it is easier oh yeah well
as far as the static it depends on the
country you're in too yeah that's true
cuz if you're in America um most Asian
like people in general they're not
always doing the stuff that other ethn
ethnicities are doing you know what do
you mean what the [__] is that supposed
to be like yeah we go to bars but most
of my Asian friends don't go like as
frequently as like other ethnicities do
as at least from my friend group oh
really so what ethnicity drinks I take
offense of it what the [__] well I mean
in America just by like whatever I think
everyone drinks but then by population
like all the Asians are at the all
activities are different you know what I
mean so like meeting girls for Asian
guys versus a white dude meeting girls
it's like different just because of
where we're at but if you go to a
different country it's probably like
flipped or something you know that's
true cuz we have to take that into
account the culture the whatever the
whatever and yeah that's pretty much
like probably why it's certain a certain
way you know also I like to think though
like pre- dating apps right it's like
it's kind of the luck of the draw with
life when you meet somebody you never
know when you're going to like meet
somebody in some way or they're going to
like kind of grab your attention where
it might be whereas you go on to a
dating app and then suddenly you have
like your pick of the litter you get to
make preference choices that weren't
available exactly that's true yeah it's
not something you can do I was looking
through his hinge and I was like dude
why are all these girls Asian and he
goes oh there's like preferences and I
looked at him and I was like what the
[__] dud he's a Filipino man though well
he can't have preferences nope cuz I got
mad cuz I was like you're being racist
yeah people get mad over everything
these days yeah I was I don't think you
can you can really win I was stewing
over it for like a
while the
biggest I think the the interesting part
about that statistic in dating
is I knew for a fact that um so uh White
husband black wife couple in interracial
marriage is a pretty high stat there's
like right now I think
390 no no no um that's wrong there
is son of a
[__] black husband white wife is
390,000
couples um what is that like Rel in the
relative that's the second biggest the
first biggest would be uh asian wife
white husband knew it so that's second
biggest yeah wow it's big so then so
then that's so then that stat it shows
that black husband white wife isn't even
in that you know what I mean like like
according to that the higher probability
is a black couple or
um a a black wife white husband oh so
like when you think of like a black dude
and a white girl that's actually not as
common as as you would assume no in that
stat so like but if if we're going based
on assuming that current CPL will turn
into
marriages that one says dating apps yeah
the dating app says that uh so the first
point will be true right cuz then it's
Asian uh girl responding to white guy so
that would be a high probability which
is the big relationship intercial
marriage so that one translates yeah but
the second one is actually black husband
white wife black husband as far as
marriages oh but the dating app doesn't
ref the dating app doesn't reflect that
interesting they just want to date Asian
oh that is interesting but they don't
want to the long-term result doesn't
technically reflect the shortterm the
short term little wewa y yeah wewa and
then so yeah the the biggest would yeah
and then so the Third I think might be
black white the black wife white husband
okay that's the SEC that's the third one
so I
think yeah uh well there might be
another they they don't have Hispanic in
here so that might actually be a higher
demographic of white Latino like
marriages but all I see is white black
and Asian and then other so that's why I
don't know the other other might be
Latino in there Burmese yeah but as as
of this figure it shows that I think
black and white couples are in total I
think they're bigger than Asian white
couples what about Asian male Latin
female bam there's no Latin in here God
damn but in here Asian M wait wait wait
that actually works for the daating
though cuz it's yeah Asian males are
hitting up the Latin females the most at
me and they're responding to women the
when it says men responding to women
that means if girls are reaching out to
Asian men their response is highest but
that's actually statistically kind of
right in our circle of friends kind of
are they ASI man and Latin Brown woman
there it is what if the response is stop
talking to me yeah yeah yeah that
changes the whole dynamic that doesn't
stop me dude you know how many times
Tiff said that to me good amount I keep
talking I don't stop dude I mean we've
touched upon this before too right like
Asian women um finding white male
counterparts I think there really is
like a a weird ass Vibe with like when
Asian dudes hear that like Asian girls
attract so much white guys like they
hate that yeah I get pissed I find it
really [__] [__] mad why is why is
that mad I can't be emotional about
explain why you're angry it's just all
these white men taking our
woman he went Latino yeah that's why he
went Mexican you know how many Asian
girls are out there right now pissed off
that altino grabbed you and took you or
they're mad I'm not a white
male you know they like a I wish Nick
was white that's the yeah why because
they saw your name and they just miss
they Mis rced me Asian girls with you
never saw your photos Asian girls are a
pretty high uh porn search too oh so
it's like it's like both right they're
like they're fetish
fetishized and sexual but they also want
to get married the most what's your porn
search uh majority definitely Chinese
you're a [__] F [__] Chinese I never
even seen a Chinese just Chinese just
China One China that's my porn Source
China the country just Donald Trump
saying China China China China China to
China just likes that she's like oh this
is great you have this on YouTube she's
like no I like that ad I like hot
Granny's trying to [__] you in your area
that is interesting I've always had
phases like I never like one ethnic or
race or whatever for Like Me growing up
it was mainly black and Latino girls
Latinas first Mexican girls mhm and then
later on it was like maybe Junior High
and on it was like more Asian and white
and then back to high school was kind of
like whoever was the hottest but not
really I feel like you're bragging and
it's making me upset
but when I moved to the sgv it was when
I went to when I moved to sgv it was all
Asian girls yeah yeah because I think it
was like the cute like it depends on the
population right cuz like when I grew
options for sure yeah the hottest girls
were black and Mexican cuz the
population was the biggest yeah so then
the Asian girls there weren't that many
and then but when you move to the sgv
it's nothing but Asians so wait did you
guys marry your preference to give more
data to those stats did I marry my
preference I mean I Married an Asian
girl okay but was that your like would
you say that was your preference in your
attractive skill I got to say Filipinos
hold it down yeah they hold it down they
throw it
[Laughter]
back you didn't marry your preference no
no I did yeah she's Filipino you know
you know what's interesting to me though
like is there a difference between a guy
who says like I like Filipino girls and
he's never been with one and a guy who
had a great experience with one and now
he likes that yeah that you know what I
mean the first guy is weird I'm Kidd
it's just like no true that might be it
sounds like a porn category the second
guy yeah cuz you have white guys that
say that about Asian girls they've never
had an Asian relationship also too it's
like it might just
be it's like they don't have access to
them maybe they don't have like in their
their neighborhood or I don't know man
cuz we're visual right so like you you
very attracted V like guys could [__]
fall madly in lust and love and Confused
of a just a look yeah so then you can
have a preference yeah right it's like a
carnal feeling of like oo I like this I
don't know why I like this they didn't
get a chance to you know see him in
person because a preference is just
basically you're more drawn to these
types of people than you are others but
I think I think it's no secret and
people love to deny this is not even a
thing but it is true that Asian cultures
instill certain values and behaviors in
asan women that make them kind of
likable to other races like it's not a
bad thing that's true yeah that's true
they do end up a little different than
like you know they're more of like the
traditional woman in that aspect right
they're taught to be like that's like C
culturally what's honorable so yeah it
will happen it'll just happen that way
and if it so happens that white dudes be
liking that [__] cuz they're sick of
something they've been dealing with and
also if it's ever been a problem for why
I like that type of woman I blame my
father father yeah that's true the daddy
issues the daddy can't just be as simple
as like that face shape I like a lot
yeah you know like because they're going
to go but not all of us have faces
shaped like that but like you but you do
but the thing the the misconception is
that you think that it'll always be a
good ending like I like Asian girls
because they're sub submissive whatever
okay let's say you do fine you get with
an Asian girl and she's not exactly what
you thought don't be mad don't be mad
bro there is there's an exception to the
rule yeah there's an
exception yeah for sure cuz I've dated
mostly only Asian girls and mixed as
well and not like none of them were like
the submissive whatever you think an
Asian girl should be do that make you
pissed huh that make you mad no I I
dated I want a [__] refund I I like
them were they dating you because you're
submissive
huh no no I don't know I don't I don't
even think about those aspects though
but the reason why the dating never
worked out just cuz we just don't like
each other anymore for whatever reason
it wasn't because like oh you're not
submissive enough or whatever you know
that's true you're not Asian enough
that's that's why I see there I I see
there is a difference in like cuz my
preferences are based off my experiences
and nobody can change that no matter how
much they say I self-hate like it's just
that's what I lived if I've never been
with him and I'm talking all this [__]
then yeah it's weird like what I don't
understand is we all grow up in the
states right so
like you can't kind of control who you
grow up around so if you're in a black
neighborhood or whatever and then those
are the access like those are the that's
the dating pool like and then the
hottest girl that in school is so so and
so or whatever and that's like who you
want to date then that's your preference
isn't it yeah yeah yeah it's it's your
surroundings are very important cuz a
lot of cuz the thing about the whole
like white and Asian relationship stuff
like a lot of them live close by
together in the same neighborhoods so it
only makes sense yeah yeah that they're
dating each other it's like if you're
the only Asian kid you got slim pickings
and everyone's like telling you you
should date your own kind and it's like
but where are they if you if your family
is the only Chinese restaurant in this
hicc ass Town what they're all ugly
there's white guys everywhere what if
they're just all ugly we can't we can't
get rid of the white guys they're
everywhere especially in the states
that's why they're probably the number
one [__] top
being in the US is different too because
like let's say you like Filipino girls
right there's a night and day difference
between a Carson hood ass Filipino chick
and like a diamond not all created equal
yeah you can't that's not even the same
thing at all I just want the more
submissive one to be
like people are looking at it the wrong
way because like you can have physical
preferences right but what will probably
give you a better probability of
sticking together and relating and
getting along is class so like class
yeah cuz there's like let's say you're a
[__] Rich ass balling Indonesian kid
and then like there's this like Rich ass
kid from Beverly Hills right you both
grew up with Maids you both grew up with
hella money you grew up doing shopping
and luxury places you have a similar
lifestyle and I noticed that like for me
I started seeing way more connections
and similarities from like like similar
up upbringing and backgrounds and family
Styles and then like
it's like if you meet their family and
they're like oh it's it reminds me of my
family relatability you're way more
connected than race mhm true you got to
have your whole value system match up
too that's
hard they got to be [__] hot yeah
well I mean like there's times where you
can have a preference and then you meet
them and either their character their
value system their
worldview quality of life or how they're
upbringing their family the class all
those things are going to play a huge
role in determining if they even make it
to the stats of marriage mhm most of it
is just the fact that they don't match
up to my stereotype that I had in my
head that's Nick Nick found his oh I'm a
so sub in a Latina that's that's like a
that's a big I [__] wish you was more
extion to the rule the biggest
complaints have you ever heard this how
like some Asian guys are like uh like
cute Asian girls will go for a mediocre
white
guy no I haven't it means that like when
like a the feel like Asians Asian girls
that View getting a a white guy as a
prize so now they're higher but it's not
a [__] dope ass white gu just like a
regular tech nerd dude but they look at
it like they got a Tom Brady but it's
like they they use that as like a
bragging thing which I think obviously
someone's doing that but I don't think
all of them are doing yeah for sure
that's very true that's very true but
then I've heard Asian dudes be mad about
that yeah you can't get mad at that bro
they're mad about like oh like you all
you did don't hate the play I hate that
game bro but it is funny to just be
pissed about that at all it is funny to
just be pissed that other people are
dating yeah that's weird it's just a
difficult kind of mindset to for me to
get in just let me be mad dude that's
why it does sound like some of these a
like you said before some of these Asian
guys felt entitled for those women like
no those are my women you're tooking
you're taking mine no we don't [__]
have any women the girl like I even know
you guys they are our women and you
don't know why those girls like those
guys anyway they could like them cuz
they're just like sweet I I usually
don't hear whatever whatever like I
don't hear that ever from females so I
think it's the way that way guys think
guys that are they have no real
experience they're not getting enough
puss dude no that's not true I think a
lot of black women say that um they
aren't getting black men yeah oh that's
right right right like I've heard of
that
stereotype complains about men not
seeking out their own race yeah then
maybe it comes from
like
your like so in in this stat right we've
heard the stat where like black women
and Asian guys get the least amount of
like swipes right that's a stat that's
pretty common in a lot of dating apps so
maybe it's a mentality of like having a
hard time dating so then so then you're
you're you're like creating different
reasons as to why it's like a
frustration
yeah or everybody's just into
middle-sized
dicks that's not it that's definitely
not or Asian guys and black girls need
to get together because blazian babies
are cute and if they're laser babies are
dope laser people just look so [__]
cool to
me anything else you want to add Anthony
no I forgot to turn on the timer 6
minutes so this is a 23 minute video
already